dans la nuit du 15 au 16 juillet 2016
des avions de chasse f16 survole la
turquie est largué une bombe sur le
parlement à ankara la capitale
les militaires déclare dans un
communiqué de presse lu sur la chaîne
publique de télévision qu'il contrôle
les abords des lieux de pouvoir et
bloque les ponts ainsi que les aéroports
il instaure un couvre-feu
recep tayyip erdogan le président turc
alors en vacances à marmaris à 650 km de
la capitale appelle le peuple à
reprendre le contrôle
avec son smartphone sur la chaîne de
télévision cnn türk
ces sympathisants descendent dans la rue
les militaires tirent sur la foule à
balles réelles
le 17 juillet richesse tayyip erdogan
rentrer à istanbul
il est acclamé par ses sympathisants il
dénonce un coup d'état fomenté selon lui
par l'imam fethullah gulen qui serait
appuyée par les états unis
les jours qui suivent voient
l'arrestation de plus de 3000 militaires
soupçonnés d'avoir pris part à cette
tentative de coup d'état une purge est
amorcé en tout plus de 7500 personnes
sont placées en garde à vue
cette tentative de coup d'état a fait
officiellement 251 morts et plus de 2000
blessés parmi les civils